the noble police officers of battlefield
hardline only have one thing on their
minds when they're chasing down
criminals and it's money whether you're
a cop or a criminal and hardline money
talks and it's the most reliable way to
get your hands on some hot new gear so
we've been dating for the best methods
of drumming up a surplus of cash and
here's what we've found
Hotwire isn't my favorite game-mode by
any means but if you can get behind the
wheel of a target car there's a lot of
money to be made for basically just
joyriding and there are a few things you
can do to maximize profit
to have some particular cater to the
strategy because of their specific
topography firstly Riptide is a sand bar
along the southernmost border of the map
that's far enough removed from the main
areas that you can basically just cruise
up and down it for a good chunk of time
before anyone even notices you're gone
if you've ever had to make your way up
to this area to stop one of the opposing
teams cars you know what a thorn this
tactic can be in the enemy's side
derailed has a similar situation the
drainage ditch in the middle of the map
may be an obvious place to hide so to
speak but I found it surprisingly easy
to pull off some long running Hotwire
captures just by driving up and down
this ditch repeatedly the bridges that
run over it allow your enemies an
opportune ambush spot so keep your eyes
peeled for explosives and try to drive
like a drunken unpredictable mess these
may seem like overly simplistic
strategies but the numbers don't lie I
haven't been able to rack up nearly as
much money nearly as fast in any other
way but please enlighten me in the
comments below if you have beyond these
general strategies it's a good idea to
keep a few other tips in mind wait until
you've amassed a bit of a crew before
rolling out to these spots having a
teammate on board to lay down some
defensive fire or repair your vehicle is
invaluable to handle encroaching foes
will you focus on the road
the stunt driver and satphone gadgets
will also augment this strategy
incredibly stunt driver enables you to
use a nitrous boost which can get you
out of a tight spot in short order and
it also increases your defense against
other cars and road hazards laying down
a Sat phone at the capture vehicle spawn
points will allow you to quickly get
back into your Hotwire groove after
you're taken off the road by a
well-placed grenade
both of these perks are fairly expensive
but I assure you you'll make back that
money in a few short rounds if you use
this tactic the strategy may not be the
most fun way to play battlefield
hardline but you'll be hard-pressed to
find an easier way to bang out a quick
10 grand in a round without breaking a
sweat
so
use it until you've unlocked all the
gear that you want and then go nuts from
there
you